Dark Souls where do I start for the
better part of a year a huge part of my
life has revolved around this game if I
could sum up how I feel about it in one
video then I wouldn't have 70 other
videos dedicated to it and if there's
any one true testament to what this game
means then you should just look at the
content in the community that has
evolved around it but essentially Dark
Souls to me is what a video game should
strive to be because games have the
potential to be something that nothing
else can not only can they put you in
control of a character or a world but
they can give you an experience they can
use gameplay and interactivity to make
you experience the world good games
realize that you aren't just a viewer
you are a player and carefully very
carefully true games can be designed so
that the player doesn't just witness the
world around them they experience it a
book can't do this a movie can't do this
sure these mediums can make you
empathize but they can't make you
experience only a game can do that I
want this game to be the one that
reminds us what some games can be so I'm
going to spend these next few minutes
reflecting on what Dark Souls is think
about Dark Souls really think about it
do you remember your first playthrough
you're dropped into this world with no
idea of what's going on so you do what
feels natural you know
you progress you struggle you fail you
struggle again and you succeed one day
you struggle for so long that you might
even give up completely and you leave
this game behind now think about what I
said in relation to the story of Dark
Souls you're an undead you can never die
but every death brings you closer to
hollowing your mind is fading and you're
in this cell with no idea what's going
on so you take the only option open to
you you progress you struggle against
the world you fail you struggle again
and you succeed one day you struggle for
so long that you give up completely
because undead can never die but every
death brings you closer to hollowing and
once you've hollowed completely you lose
all hope so the reason I said a similar
thing twice is because the gameplay just
mirrored and experienced this is the
story of an undead who gives up hope
it's the experience of a player who
fights against dark souls this is a game
that has depth because it focuses on the
experience and Dark Souls is known as a
difficult game it's the story of an
undead human in a world where everything
is out to kill him
a world where dying as this undead is a
traumatizing experience that you have to
try and push through just like dying as
a player is an irritating experience
that you have to overcome so it makes
sense you know that you should have
trouble progressing in this game
sometimes what a lot of people don't
understand is that Dark Souls isn't
difficult for the sake of being
difficult its difficulty comes as a
result of a deeper design philosophy
from software have actively designed
their game around something that only
games have a failure state death in
video games is something we take for
granted at this point but in Dark Souls
death and failure are designed to give
you that feeling of struggle and triumph
it's also used to immerse yourself in a
world where death doesn't end your life
but it brings you closer and closer to
giving up people often say it's too
difficult or it doesn't explain things
to you
these are insults leveled at the Soul
series regularly and they're right Dark
Souls is too difficult for some people
Dark Souls also doesn't go out of its
way to explain things to you but here's
something you have to understand about
Dark Souls it's a game that doesn't dumb
down the experience for the benefit of
the so called mass-market appeal it does
its own thing regardless of whether some
people will be turned off and in doing
so it's become something infinitely more
valuable and pure Fromm's philosophy
revolves around making this good game
first and trusting that people will come
and this has happened slowly you know
Demon Souls came out and it was a niche
hit Dark Souls came out and even 2 years
after the game came out people are still
picking it up due to word-of-mouth as a
result the soul series doesn't need huge
marketing efforts behind it because it's
become this industry icon through
word-of-mouth and people telling each
other they should play it you know
someone said something really great to
me recently he said you know from
software they aren't afraid to put
things in their game that people will
miss
and that's such a perfectly beautiful
statement if I had to choose any
statement that represented Dark Souls
I'd probably choose this one it's the
reason the game has so much depth
because they don't compromise on game
design just so every player can see an
area or so that every player can
understand and play their game as soon
as they start when I say that you might
not see certain things I'm not just
talking about how the dlc is located in
a hard-to-see cave near an optional boss
that can only be accessed if you kill
certain enemies in the right order no
I'm also talking about how they don't
shove the story down your throat or how
the game locks you out of certain areas
if you're not good enough to beat them
let me explain that better imagine if
you were reading a book you're reading a
book and then all of a sudden the book
shuts itself and says stop you're not
good enough to read me I'm going to lock
away parts so you have to earn them Dark
Souls sets itself apart from other games
in this way and this is just one of the
reasons it's come to be considered a
pure gaming experience it's something I
think that could help games remember
what they can be I think games should
generally focus on what makes them
different from other forms of media and
that's something that from software has
captured in a lot of different ways but
Dark Souls doesn't just lock you out of
content by being difficult in fact I
think one of the biggest reasons Dark
Souls is considered difficult is not
because it's hard but because it's hard
to get into and while I see this as a
bit of a problem since they plan to fix
this in Dark Souls 2 and make the game
more accessible some fans will even
argue that the inaccessibility of Dark
Souls is a plus because it makes those
first few hours of torment and struggle
even more rewarding when you finally
learn how to play but it's not just the
gameplay in Dark Souls that's cryptic
and anyone who's on my channel knows
this Dark Souls also approached the
concept of story in a game in a unique
way the story elements are cryptic and
hidden down to the last little detail
and while you might have some idea of
what happened by the end of the game
most players actually just end up
thinking why the [ __ ] am I on fire
there's actually a beautiful little
story behind why the souls games were
created with these cryptic hidden
stories I'm sure many of you have
realized this but Dark Souls is a West
installed RPG created in Japan and
that's a bit strange
it even has English voice actors to
convey this feeling more accurately so
why is this why is this a vision
well when miyazaki the game's director
was a child he loved reading western
fantasy
he loved the stories the settings and he
was inspired and so Dark Souls was
created in this Western RPG format but
there's more to this story Miyazaki
couldn't read English very well so when
he read these Western fantasy novels he
had gaps and you might be able to see
where I'm going with this some parts of
these books he just couldn't read and so
while he had this vision of decaying
castles and brave knights he had to use
his imagination to fill the gaps and in
doing so he created a story that was
partly his own and a story that was
richer because of this fact sound
familiar
when we play Dark Souls we create our
own stories just like Miyazaki did we
read item descriptions we listen to
dialogue and from the bones and
fragments of a story we slowly carefully
craft this vision of a world some people
like me bring this vision to life
through videos we call this vision law
some of us share our law with others and
discover other people's stories on image
boards and forums inspiring and
challenging great ideas and this is what
has kept this incredible community alive
way longer than you'd expect by creating
a game that intentionally leaves things
for you to discover and speculate on we
now have one of the strongest
communities on YouTube and we exist
across hundreds of pages of forums and
wikis there's a reason people were still
coming into this game years after the
initial marketing push it's because we
in the Dark Souls community talked about
this game we share our experiences and
there are thousands of people who play
just because they get that comment from
a friend that says dude you have to play
this game or when someone says you
haven't played Dark Souls I can't
imagine not having a friend to talk to
about my experiences in this game you
know
the thrill you get when your world is
invaded by another player or the venting
of frustration that you have to do when
you've been stuck on a boss for four
hours and then the eventual ecstasy you
get when you overcome an obstacle that
was in your way it's just one of those
games that was destined to find a home
on the internet full of people who need
to share and tell others about this
experience and in this way the game
actually kind of sells itself I recently
got invited to the Namco Bandai offices
in San Jose in the States and I managed
to meet all these people who were behind
the marketing of Dark Souls and Dark
Souls 2 and the thing is they realized
that this game is different they
realized it has this effect on people
where word-of-mouth will sell their game
and really they just have to allow from
software to fulfill their vision and I
can't think of any better publisher to
publish this actually I met with Brian
Hong who's the director of marketing for
Dark Souls and Dark Souls 2 and he put
it so well they don't have to change
Dark Souls to suit the market just like
Apple didn't create a PC to suit the
market the market eventually realized
their vision and came around to them and
that's what I think is happening with
Dark Souls and I think this is a game
that will come to define a generation
and I'm actually honored to be a part of
it with you guys soon you'll be able to
click here and Kindle the bonfire so
that we can make this channel better
together in the comments of this video
I'd love for you to tell me your
favorite little piece of gameplay design
and Dark Souls I could have made this
video much longer if I talked about all
my favorite mechanics and bits but I
decided to keep it short but sweet for
example though I could quote so many
beautiful pieces of gameplay design from
the design works book and these have
interviews with the director and the
developers so I think I might just read
one of my favorite quotes right now so
one of them is about his design of the
undead the undead dragon and he says and
Miyazaki says most people don't believe
me when I say this but a certain kind of
refinement elegance and dignity are very
important to me I usually tell the
designers that flat-out grotesque or
splatter type designs will not get past
me this has everything to do with my own
personal sensibilities and it's
something that I apply to every design
that I
it's a little hard to describe if you
were to ask me well what do you mean by
dignity I guess the best answer I can
provide you is right here in this book
in every design in Dark Souls you see
within these pages my idea of dignity is
something that I pursue with every
project I work on and then one of the
other designers tells the story he says
I remember when I was drawing the undead
dragon I submitted a design draft that
depicted a dragon swarming with maggots
and other gross things Miyazaki handed
this back to me saying this isn't
dignified don't rely on the gross factor
to portray an undead dragon can't you
instead try to convey the deep sorrow of
a magnificent beast doomed to a slow and
possible endless descent into ruin and
like just look at how they succeeded
with this in terms of design this is an
undead dragon doomed to live the rest of
its life clean to cliffs while its
brethren fly through the skies and
instead it's here rotting away if you
aggravated it tries to breathe fire but
vomits out bile and poison instead I
challenge you guys to look deeper into
every aspect of design in this game and
for example where some people just see a
rotting dragon others will see that deep
sorrow of a magnificent beast doomed to
die a slow and possibly endless descent
into ruin anyway I'll catch you guys
next time as we dive headfirst into Dark
Souls 2 there's going to be so much
content on this channel so keep your
eyes out later